she was thinking what lies can i can i
tell
because
there's no way out he's recording the
whole thing yeah he's got you on dashcam
saying that you got chirps in a shop
that's giggling
[Music]
all right guys
we're here
let's go guys i was going to say we're
queer i knew you were i was like i know
you were so busy
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh yeah that's it that's it that's it's
not as [ __ ] lord we grew up that's
jokes
you can't just say you mean it you can't
say stuff [ __ ] it out
that's jokes
guys welcome back happy monday your boys
are here we're excited we've got a super
juicy episode that we're going to go
through today juicy juicy
um and guys to start off what we need
you to do is quickly
pause the episode head on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
and over there guys you're gonna find
years of bonus content three years kind
of stuff when we didn't even know what
we were doing kind of content facts the
old stuff old stuff uncensored unsexed
on structures
um so the og foundations are over there
on patreon guys on top of that you get
an episode every single thursday
of the year guys number we don't care
what time of year we don't care if it's
christmas day guys you're going to give
yourself an episode an episode every
single thursday without fail guys and on
top of that you really are indoctrinated
into the cult babies okay the sng cult
babies there's only a few there's only a
handful yeah i say a few but there is
quite a few there's quite a few but it's
only a few yeah you know it's not enough
for like we need enough people for a
small country that's the kind of cult
which one they're not there yet yeah
yeah that's the kind of trouble cult
we're trying to have here guys bring him
in so if you can just
head on over yeah it's three pound a
month 10p a day you gotta run the peter
sng guys um and that's that's how you
become indoctrinated into the cult very
very very small joining fee okay
very small joining retainer retainer
there you go a little bit of retainer
there you go um also guys if you are
listening to this episode on spotify or
itunes or
prime or whatever it is that you listen
to um our sexy voices on please for the
love of god leave us a nice rating five
stars is preferable but you're not
essential if that's not how you feel
tell us how you really feel
leave us a nice review as well and uh it
really really
authentically i'm not just saying this
this i actually does wonders for us
in the kind of
scope of where we're trying to reach you
know your boys are trying to be the
biggest podcast in the game and the only
way we can do that is if you guys help
spread the word you give us say nice
things about us sucks spotify then look
at that and say that's cool maybe a few
more people might like that and
sometimes
um
and then we take over because that's the
game that is the game your boys came
from nothing and now we're something
yeah your boys came from nothing and we
want to be everything we want to be
we're selfish we also got a little taste
of it we've got a little bit
stuff we can't go back
long story short we can't go back to
what we were yeah yeah i need these
weekly trims and i need these weekly
garms yeah
so three pound a month 10p a day
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
you heard it there first factual it's
literally factual
we're desperate we're desperate um and
also guys if you are watching on youtube
please like the video if you liked the
video chirp sitting in the comments we
need the breeding grounds for the cult
babies
um and also guys ring that notification
bell and subscribe to the channel
play and without any further ado
your co-host of the day you know your
dark-skinned danger you know the sea
serpent himself okay
dragon wrangler okay
okay [ __ ] tangling okay let's go fire
lord fueg come on with the fun fact of
the day let's get monday started right
come on
so the fun fact of the day is actually
um a little game
that i've deduced for you the title is
famous people famous initials famous
people famous initials okay okay what
the rules there are no rules you just
have to try and guess
all right
guess you're going to say some initial
guess who the famous person is yeah no
i'm just going to i'm going to guess i'm
going to say the name and you're going
to try and guess what the initial is
you're going to
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
so samuel l jackson what does the l
stand for what do you think the l oh
oh god samuel l jackson yeah
what do you think the l stands for
obviously guys player home comments all
of that all of that good stuff samuel l
jackson the l in samuel right how old is
he's [ __ ] old yeah so he's probably
60 something 77
uh
i don't know man leonard comes to mind
not too far off what is it leroy
i should have said i should have of
course
oh now he looks like a little right here
yeah
oh dear lee roy yeah yeah that's this is
why he left it out yeah
seymour samuel leroy jackson is his full
name
yeah jk rowling jk rowling yeah
jk rowling what is jk rowling's actual
person yeah exactly jk rowling
is it okay
is it a hyphenated name no okay so it's
it's a name and a name yeah all right
i'm gonna go with
julia king
try another guess all right
did i get both of them wrong of course
yeah of course okay
is it a white english name or do you got
like a hippie name no no no no both
white
both white
right um common name the first j
yeah i would say very pretty common yeah
jane
courtney rowling
joanne
kathleen okay
i was never getting cancer yeah i know
you would but jane joanne not too bad
all right fair play joanne kathleen
rowland jk rowling this one you're never
gonna get taraji p henson
what does the p stand for
it's probably probably you're never
probably congolese or size it's probably
it's already a silent p
yeah
the p is definitely a click
a silent p
[ __ ] sake um
mnemonic
um
let's go with
uh
i'm gonna go with something like stupid
like peace
panda panda what even is that
that's not even a word bro i say you're
never gonna get it pender
yeah
mary j blige oh
has to be jane
thank god
has to be all right cool
d.l hughley
for those i know he's a comedian actor
d l hewgley
i feel like his first name is daryl gang
yes bro
um
l is
he looks like another leroy to be fair
the way he dresses with a slightly hat
1970s [ __ ] yeah
um i will go levi
lin lit yeah
i didn't name him
so these were getting somewhere yeah all
right next one
oh j simpson oh my god orange juice
orange juice simpson um
oj simpson i'm gonna go with oh [ __ ] oh
oh
the thing is he oh he's so famous bad
people probably know his name you'll be
surprised yeah i have i never knew his
name until the day i found out yeah i
have no idea i'm gonna go with oh what
the [ __ ] is obro who begins with o
america is it like an american name
i guess i don't know and i heard his
name in your life no oh okay there
um
oj
i'm gonna go start with the j
[Music]
and go with
either james or joseph
you got the j
you're never getting that oh odell
no
you're never getting it all right if
you've never even heard of it i don't
even know where i'm going orinthal oren
thought yeah orin thor so o r e n h
orenthal orienthal james simpson
stupid sounds like saying out of thor i
no wonder he shortened to oh yeah o.j
michael b jordan
michael b jordan the b stands for
bradley
no
is it nigger-ish
yeah but not the
not the niggerish you're thinking all
right cool um
um
is it
um
um
b the b
michael b john sounds for
bryce no that's not niggerish at all
i don't know
backery
he probably pronounces it bakari
definitely does yeah but
it's bakery stuff
oh jesus they definitely called him
blackery in school
they
definitely oh i've not even put two and
two together
oh
[Music]
that's annoyed me that's annoyed me
[ __ ] i hate to be you michael b i hate
had to be [ __ ] all right you might get
this one i'm pretty sure you might get
this one as well jf
kennedy i know it's john
john f kennedy uh john
they come from a pretty like powerful
family i'm pretty sure so it's something
like a nice powerful american name
from the 80s oh he was probably born in
the 60s
john
franklin
no but i like where your heads at in
terms of like powerful names and stuff
like that
john i like where your head's up
frederick
i'll give you one more
oh john
francis no fitzgerald
but it's along the ballpark of where you
were gonna
where you were where you were at
you're never getting this one
vivica a fox
a tinter kumbak
that's what it probably is
wow i was not expecting that
wow
um
okay i know it's a stupid [ __ ] name i
already know how many syllables is it
four i'm not doing it
just tell me what it is anjanetta
yeah
that oh my god that's a lot that's a lot
last but not least last but not least
sorry bj novak
you know that is right yeah for those i
know bretta played um ryan in the office
the american office
he looks like uh
brian john
i guess again
they are very like basic
english back-to-back names apart from
the novak obviously um
ben yeah looks like a ben but longer
version benjamin
yes
he looks like another james to be fair
it's not james
what's another popular jay
think biblical uh
joseph gang
all right so bj novak benjamin joseph
novak all right best so yeah famous
people famous names i gave you 10. that
was stressful that was fun though yeah
that was cool that was a fun fact very
very nice you're mixing it up today i
like it
right guys
i know we are so
full context we were away on holiday so
the episodes that have been coming out
are delayed yeah i know you man i'm
thinking where is the juice yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so for context
i received so many messages about this i
love you man for it yeah
so
one thing you
you'll slowly start to learn
is that
the s g cult has influences
all over the place yeah so when we say
you think it's all jokes yeah yeah we
say
india has seven days to get a deal
otherwise shit's gonna happen
hey i think we did it in like three days
i think so i screamed about man united
and then the same day started dubbing
you know so
we've got we've got our hands in every
pie all right let's start with united
and move on to india so
it was going to be a rant but it's not
around it's more like a follow-up about
how happy i am
about where we are in the table so
treat me like i don't know anything
so um the back story is
i had a huge ass around a few weeks ago
about united because
first game of the season we lost to
brighton 2-1 we played horribly second
game of the season we lost four nil to
brent first brentford and we played
absolute dog [ __ ] yeah and he tucked us
in four nil in the first half fun fact
it was not that goal i told you about
was nominated for goal of the month but
it didn't win
and you would be nominated yeah there
were goals last month there were goals
last month james [ __ ]
um so now where we're at is so that was
a few weeks ago the game after that we
played southampton
and we managed to win a one-nil away win
still still a clean sheet
still a win but not convincing okay
because it's like one nil is a risky
business one of those risky business
anywhere only by one point that's too
risky
second game we played um
who did we play away we played leicester
away
and leicester need to win they've lost
now they've lost six game on bounce oh
six games on the bounce their bottom of
the table with one point which is one
draw they've drawn once and lost five
so we're going into this game thinking
we're away we're at their ends we have
to win regardless because we need to
come and up and up they need to their
lives are on the line yeah yeah yeah
their lives are on the line they're
gonna play they're gonna play and the
coach's neck is on the drawing board
yeah yeah because if he loses any more
yeah he's gone yeah he's gone yeah yeah
do you know what i mean yeah
another tough one they'll win
clean sheet but we're in it bag of
yellow cards
yellow cards we have to fight for crappy
we have to go fight for it yeah we both
had to fight for it we both needed it
yeah yeah we both needed yeah yeah and
then last week we played arsenal
we played arsenal and i was thinking we
have to tuck these men in because these
men are a five nil streak just winning
winning win and win and winning
and they're getting too gassed as much
as i spoke about them in my last rant
applauding them and stuff
that was then this is now yeah when it's
head-to-head you're going to care less
about you yeah [ __ ] off do you know what
i mean but when it comes to actual
watching football and i can appreciate
you man a little bit you know what i
mean i'm a football fan as much as i am
not as much as i may not have fan but i
love football yeah i can appreciate
stuff do you know what i mean
but we were at home and i told you last
season they tucked us in three one yeah
yeah jacquard scored a banger last
season
and it [ __ ] me up
and i'm thinking jack i can't do that
again today you can't do that again
today do you know what i mean yeah all
right so we've had
three wins on the bounce prior to this
arsenal game right and i'm thinking
energy's up we've got we signed anthony
from iax he was our he was the last
person we needed to sign before the
deadline um they closed 100 m's 100 m
euros so that's like 80 something mil
and he's our second or third highest
we've spent in the transfer window
so he we actually started him and i was
like okay gang the lineup looked good
arsenal lineup looked good as well
thinking this is gonna be a game yeah
this is gonna be a game and i'm here for
it i'm here for it so first 15 minutes
or first 10 minutes i would say
possession wise we were dominating
dominance thinking okay we're playing
football arsenal counter
they foul um
they get erickson off the ball
and they pass to gabriel martinelli man
bangs it over there scores a goal and
i'm thinking [ __ ]
[ __ ] after all that after all that good
10 first 10 minutes yeah what the [ __ ]
is going on buddy
quick var
foul on eriksen they washed away that
girl guys like suck all your mom
we're winning this game yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so before half time now
i think erickson passes the ball to
uh bruno fernandez bruno fernandez
passes the ball to rashford rashes to
passes it to anthony our new signing
he's on a right wing so he's just
cutting his first time just pings it
around him with his left just go fam the
way the arena erupted i bet he attracted
the first touch on this cross first not
his first touch in the grass but it was
a first touch goal so he didn't take a
touch
first time goal he didn't take a touch
the first time left foot curl it curled
it right back
fam the stage of me rocked i was [ __ ]
better lest he was banging his chest on
the badge
you're on the bench i am stuck i'm the
real anthony's first name is anthony as
well i'm the real anthony yeah yeah this
is what they pay the bucks this is why i
make the big money that's why i make the
big money you want to look some academy
thing
but say unless we're on the same team
some allow you yeah
yeah one nil boom halftime we go out we
go in
they come back now a little tiki takka
sucker scores a goal they get gassed
obviously as they do yeah 1-1 as they do
but we're at ot we're playing much
better football erickson
has the thing about erickson the thing i
love about erickson eriksen knows and
cassamira does this as well erickson
knows who to pass the ball to before two
two passes before he's even got the ball
oh gang yeah he's always scanning the
field as all great midfielders should do
as any great player should be period but
he's always scanning the field and he
always knows where to go and where to go
next i say always probably eight slash
nine times out of ten he does other he's
human makes mistakes of course
um
so second goal i think
he must have got the ball off someone
passed it to bruno fernandez bruno
fernandez did one dirty outside of the
right foot pass
rashford cut through free man i heard
russia was on [ __ ] he was on he her
rashford was pacing
down the line got in just slid it past
my man slid it past ramsdale 2-1 erupted
going erupted
same again i think about it was about 10
minutes later
similar similar thing i can't remember i
think bruno fernandez passed in the ball
again so assisted him the ball again
same thing cut through the defenders
bang scored again i was thinking three
one gang and i think around 17 minutes
anthony came off and put ronaldo on so
and ronaldo changed the whole game yeah
because it was it was a case of
everyone started to cluster around him
which freed up so many other man so the
way we're playing is so tactical now
yeah so this is the main reason why i
see that
um eric 10 haagen wanted to keep ronaldo
because obviously the speculation went
out of government this and that's we
spoke about in previous episodes
but we needed that change of pace that
change of injection so if he comes on as
a sub every big man they've been going
all out for 70 minutes the opposition
yeah now we're bringing him a nail gun
chill he's got fresh legs
i mean he's got fresh legs and he wants
to score third he's not scored this
season
it's game five
he's not scored this season
he's hungry he's starving he's hungry
yeah he's never gone this long
that's actual fact yeah yeah do you know
what i mean so yeah every man was
worried so i understand the main reason
why he wanted to keep him and why
the tactics are working the way they
were because we're playing great
football no no that's not playing great
football we're playing really good
football
and it's going to take
that much that bit much more of pressure
to take us to that next level and i
think that pressure will come with these
next coming days or these next coming
weeks rather and we've got a lot of
midweek games because um the
europa league champions league all these
cup games they're all midweek so that's
happening pretty soon so by the time
this one comes out we would have played
two games we would have played our
europa game
um and we would have played our game
against crystal palace away which is on
sunday and that's going to be a hard
game all right i really know that's
going to be a hard game they tucked us
in twice last season i think we drew one
and we lost the last game of the season
which was one nil to them all right and
we played away all right so i'm fixed so
yeah i'm hoping i'm hoping
i think our europa game is at home i'm
pretty sure he's at home and i'm pretty
sure we're going to tuck him in but i
think the crystal palace game is going
to be hard but we're going to win 2-1
mark my words calm we're going to win
2-1 crystal palace and we're probably
going to win maybe 3-0 or 4-1 the europa
game
so i'm very confident
we've united right now i'm very
confident all right all right anthony
start the way the way we're playing we
are playing with and we've got people on
the bench like casimiro casimiro and
ronaldo on the bench having just those
two on the bench that's a that's a huge
positive yeah yeah and the person that's
taking casimir out of the position is
a guy called scott mctominay who hasn't
been
as um white as the united fans would say
hasn't been the best midfielder but when
you have someone that's there to
potentially take your place you step
your [ __ ] oh yeah yeah and he's
fighting for the ball he's doing bits in
midfield now which he has been doing but
he's doing it with more common sense and
he's doing it with the help of everyone
else so we don't every player doesn't
keep the ball for that long if as soon
as you get the ball you need to know who
you're passing to straight away because
that's how we just have to play
that's flow that's literally that's r b
absolutely it's river and blues bro and
we're we're playing we're playing all
right we're playing and i'm happy and
we're in a good place for you bro i'm in
a good place
good place yes ma'am
is off the bounce i'm happy yeah that's
that's what i like since that rant yeah
man i'm guessing let's go cool so now
we're gonna move on to india so if you
guys don't remember
your boys set out some very clear
guidelines
that the fashion industry um
were just moving racist facts and it was
uh exclusionary and it was very
offensive yeah so basically
we
couldn't sit by and watch not anymore
yeah
we couldn't sit by and just watch india
the
the the national treasure yeah the
nation sweetheart not pick up some
six-figure deals the way her peers from
love island would just clean your necks
all these other years from love around
we're cleaning up ecken sue is [ __ ]
on man yeah
she's not on neck and sue level yeah
she's not looking suzaki and l.a doing
what she wants
he doesn't give a [ __ ]
um
but
yes so
india got a deal she says you've got two
deals you've got two dozen spaces like
two three days yeah yeah so it's the
first deal she got were boots now the
boost one i actually like so most loads
of people messaged me were like oh she
got a deal she got a deal but a lot of
people messaging me like ah she's got a
deal but hey it's boots like what the
[ __ ] is boots yeah you might need to
relax because boots is in every corner
of england not only is it in every
corner of england it is a stadium of
english culture yeah it's not some
e-commerce [ __ ] website boots ain't
going anywhere bruce has been here boots
is not going anywhere that's longevity
bro boots is a staple yeah and demands
is racist as they come
the queen's probably been in boots
boost races they come so for them to
patent up india yeah yeah with this rose
petal background that they had which was
looking lavish by the way um
india was glowing she was she was
glowing
they oiled us
yeah
so yeah yeah yeah but that first
that was wholesome a lot of people like
how [ __ ] boots bruce is
banging and if you're a chick who knows
anything about makeup yeah boots they
keep that high enough yeah they do yeah
yeah yeah they keep that kylie jenner's
[ __ ] yeah they do yeah yeah
they keep it stush yeah so yeah this is
the one that's the shoes
because boots wholesome as hell they do
meal deals in boots
boosted what they want boosted at one
there used to be a girl with down
syndrome needs to work on my boots
um she worked there for years they take
care of amanda she was terrible
oh blessed she was terrible yes um she
was downs as hell bro and they just had
her on the on the checkout and every
time she took me a check i was like [ __ ]
because i'm gonna be here for a minute
now
she was [ __ ] but they never sacked her
man so boots take care of their own bro
so india is good to be in there um and
the second one was asos marketplace was
it asos is
i don't know what the [ __ ] that is but
hey he said that she's the first
ambassador yeah first ambassador for the
marketplace i don't know [ __ ] the
marketplace it's not my job marketplaces
i just hope it's money lucrative yeah we
just care about money over here we don't
care about semantics yes
as long as it's lucrative
how much am i taking yeah after
everything is said and done how much am
i talking about the cuts yeah what are
my percentages what's my take home
that's why i don't care about
marketplace this that deal i don't care
what titles bro what's the bag say
that's all i need to know so she patting
up two in the same week so we're happy
we're gassed we're happy india good and
i'm not even gonna start making demands
this week for next man the mandem are
[ __ ] oh they're not doing they're not
doing anything anything man they're
seeing a man on tick tock just doing
doing this [ __ ] this glasses got face
to face
sunglasses
i'm not i'm not going to make demands
because you might not even get hard done
by you aren't even putting they're not
paid you're not doing nothing about oh
yeah you might have just out here
letting your women just collect bags but
i'm trying to think
i can't remember
because i've probably been watching love
island for maybe three years
maybe four three or four years and i
can't remember a bread to clean up a
immediately after or not even
necessarily immediately but like a
couple months after love island has
finished while guam for what's his face
light skin brother the one brother no
the skinny brother where's
where oh i'd see i didn't watch love
island that year so i saw i watched love
love island the year after that
did he clean up straight away to be fair
i don't know about straight away that's
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying i
don't know about sin oh of course yeah
yeah he's cake he does what he wants
he's a millionaire he drives what he
wants what he
to take anything and and ended up taking
everything yeah and i can't even judge
you because it's going at all now he's
going all now yeah
um and who else make i don't know how
much money that white guy makes that
buff white guy
jack yeah yeah yeah he makes bags i
don't know how much he i don't i don't
think he makes
wears nelson bags he makes bags he does
me i don't know what he made straight
after though
that again could be years in the making
but um you might be right i can't think
of any brothers and the only other guy
that i know that's doing stuff because
we follow him is um
uh mac griffiths
he's two wow he's two uh i can't
remember he's he's changed his name he's
not his name's not actually mac it's
something else but he changed his like
alias to mack i can't remember his
actual name but yeah um him he's on
everyone's sponsoring in different
things so he's on his job obviously the
gym
and the other bit of uh
jordan he's on he's doing some eclectic
yeah
he's doing long leg shoots didn't he
[Laughter]
on an eclectic long leg shoots
man he's on stuff
he's on a different level of fashion
absolutely because that can never be me
it can never be me he wears them i i
swear
he looks like this is the funniest thing
you've ever done james
it's the only way i could describe it
that's what he's on he's on a low angle
camera listening he loves long limbs
he loves himself on long limbs oh he's
too funny he loves flares and two
yeah flares and tummies yeah yeah
knitted tummy tucked in yeah knitted
crop tops massive glasses glasses wedged
up shoes as well with the toes out and
then aristocrat you know those frilly
neck things
from back a day he likes dancing there
oh he's on a different way yeah he's on
different i don't know what bags he's
collecting from this
i had never seen him that much on like
soldiers and stuff
but i think prior to me seeing him um
come into the restaurant i seen a few um
reposts and stuff and i seen how he
dressed i was like oh wrong maybe he's
doing this because he's
doing some couple brand deals but when i
saw him rock up he was wearing something
pretty similar like he had his toes out
he has like some flares do you know what
i mean he loves it he loves it was the
nails painted
i don't think no no cause this was
this was probably
a year and a half ago and i think mandem
wasn't wasn't as white as now yeah yeah
yeah you know what i mean i was sort of
painting it now
i'm just saying they probably are yeah
probably yeah yeah oh he loves it and i
love that for him yeah so fast he posted
a video of some matte green card the
other day which is i think i was walking
past this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
probably a dead whip i saw it i'm sorry
just walking past it
yeah yeah i think the fashion matched it
as well yeah yeah yeah so i played to
him so man okay okay cool so the amanda
much slow starters yeah man them a slow
slide it makes sense it does make sense
it's easy it's easier more easily
accessible for the women in terms of all
these fashion deals because quick quick
yeah women go through fashion yeah they
do go through it they do
wait in three years oh there were
they've been dresses over the past few
years that have been like staple months
of dresses like this um
a few years ago there was
i could see my head but i don't realize
it scrap describe it it was like a green
and red one that had like um the boobs
was that it was short
everyone had like a green it was like a
neon green and reddish type
yeah everyone had it i know now
everyone's on this mesh net one that you
see everywhere with like the shorts here
yeah bro these man moves faster they get
through [ __ ] quick so yeah they need to
snag up the girls while they're hot and
then just go go go go go go go go go go
go
this is i don't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah so
the man are there a bit slow burner but
once they get going you get mad like
where's that just like bro i need
everything yeah you give me all the bags
and he makes he's he's got a song with
someone who's someone i can't remember
who it was but i remember it was like
such and such was nelson i was like are
you serious
are you serious but fair enough um so
well done india yeah man um mandem we'll
see you on the other side uh hopefully
that patterns well done united let's
keep that going i've got a quick trash
news which is also another big big big
praise okay
so someone i'm a big fan of um mr beast
you see this yes i did bro
yes i did open up his own [ __ ] um
burgers join ten thousand people queued
up in the oh my god burgers ever sold in
a day restaurant yeah in a day ever ever
[ __ ] yeah i saw that i think yesterday
yeah yeah bro [ __ ] man mr beast is
killing it killing the video yes the
whole movie yes
yes i did bro yeah did you know the
story of how beast burger started no
it's really really cool so the cool
thing about mr beast is obviously he
reinvests all his money i think
yeah
about into his videos and he barely
takes home any money he only cares about
making videos and making really really
good products but he also does a lot of
good wholesome charity work
so he does like turkey dried like
thanksgiving like these turkey dries and
food drives and stuff like that and like
on the weekends like he said when he
started and he turns it into content
um and now he does all these like food
box donations and stuff like that and so
many people turn up to them okay and
because the videos get so popular and
people keep coming and coming and now he
gives away so much free food and then
obviously people end up what he ends up
doing is getting a sponsor for that
video okay um and the company will
approach him like oh we want to sponsor
a video but cool you can sponsor this
video and i'll use that money to buy the
food for these food boxes so he's always
given
a bank
way beast burger started
i'm pretty sure he said it was during
covid
was where um he wanted
to
he likes stuff that's like a little bit
more healthy he's got a beast burger and
he's got something else as well so he's
passionate about like health and all
that stuff yeah but during uh he wanted
to do like a burger and i don't think
it's anything special it's just like a
standard burger but um what he was doing
was is he would just um instead of
opening his own spot which he's done now
yeah he would approach struggling
restaurants during covert because
obviously
he could only do takeout yeah
options okay so what he was doing was he
would approach them but look um
if you i'll
if you just like take the ingredients
um for my beast burger
anytime you get an order yeah um through
the app if you're just gonna order beast
burgers yeah you'll be their closest one
you'll get the order will go straight to
your restaurant you just make the burger
to my specifications deliver it you can
keep x percentage of the the ting and he
was doing it and people um
i don't know how much of it is true but
i believe him he's saying that a lot of
restaurants because just because because
of the popularity of the burger where
they were able to stay in business
oh say
they weren't able to open their doors
and they didn't have takeout options
what's in this burger blood bro it's
just popular because he's mr beast oh my
god so yeah so now he's opened his up
his own joint and people oh ten thousand
yeah he was nuts i'm sure it would have
been bigger than 10 000 if they
just kept going keep going as well but
um massive props to mr massive massive
possibility he is sat in an else yeah
he's killing the youtube game yeah he's
healing crushing it
so yeah big big big big big props to him
uh in a big way he does he does [ __ ]
different very much because even so did
i tell you he does is um
he does the same videos in different
languages did i tell you that i think
you did maybe probably first yeah so he
hires like voice actors
to do
voiceovers of his videos
um and he hires really good like actual
like for the japanese he's got like a
japanese channel and like we'll hire
like
anime voice actors wow to do like the
voices so you can get them all different
languages those channels like they all
have like over a million subscribers and
stuff like that wow
he's killing it [ __ ] because the beast
is a force of nature literally he is a
beast he literally is a beast he is a
beast um so big props to mr that was my
question um quick quick trash news but
i've got just before continue yeah
another trash news
another trash news that i like
um did you hear actually i think i need
to bring this one
[Music]
i thought i had on my phone never mind
um
did you hear about homeboy so there was
a guy
um
basically the the story was
um
pilot threatens to turn the plane around
if a guy so there was a guy sending
nudes air dropping nudes on a flight do
you see this no i never so there's a
story where basically the pilot had to
send out uh like um
the pilot had to send out actually no no
no no i think i do have it i think i do
have it i just didn't save into my
pictures hang on one sec yeah say this
so yeah pilot threatens to turn playing
around if passenger kiss continues to
airdrop nudes so basically what happened
was
um there was these people on a flight
yeah to
um
cabo cabo mexico i think um
and um
bro basically what happened was is uh
there was a girl who spoke to the press
afterwards and she was like
oh we were all on the flight chilling
and all of a sudden i looked to my phone
and i had an airdrop request so i
rejected it i could see through the seat
in front of me and the two women in the
seat in front of me accepted it just
[ __ ]
just
some bread was just sending his [ __ ]
round oh just like she's
to the point where the pilot was like yo
whoever's doing his air dropping
i swear down i will turn the plane
around bro we'll go back to the airport
and everyone's getting off i'm getting
secured to search everyone stop it
whoever it is stop it
and it [ __ ] sweetened me [ __ ] and you
know what sweetened me the
most i know for a fact
if it was titties
no one's saying no i said every man is
keeping a hot tub yeah hush hush on a
send me morty
what do you accept you look up man you
look up to zoo who's giggling bro you're
giggling right i want to see them t yeah
right so in my head i'm thinking jokes
even the pilot yeah because the thing
was the the chick who spoke to the uh
the press after said she rejected it so
i'm thinking
my innate thing would be if someone's
trying to send me an airdrop i'm
rejecting anything all right
no no no so obviously i'm thinking in my
head i'm like
it definitely definitely definitely the
man that was it was braves that were
complaining
the yes would have been like yuck yeah
yeah turn the phone it's the husband's
family all the husbands and the
boyfriends all that happened was to say
it's a 50 50 split yeah
male to female yeah every man saw a
little do-do-do air-dropping yeah other
thing and they said [ __ ] kitten 13
wants to send you something [ __ ] kit it
was first thing was to send you
something yeah yeah
oh did i just
accept that
i'm answer and then just so [ __ ]
and then
i'm man
hey
he's nah
he's he's air dropping [ __ ] he's here
dropping stuff bro
and it goes like why did you just reject
it i just rejected it
i tried to reject it but
who said nah who's sending stuff bruv
and then the pilot's like nah bruh [ __ ]
you you can hear man
no bro
i swear
next monday starts air dropping me dicks
i'm turning the thing around around bro
the pilot got gassed immediately [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and saw lynch saw
girthy heavy dick i was like
i swear to god we'll go back to the
airport and every man is getting
searched
you think it's a game don't send me dick
again brother i [ __ ] dare you that is
hilarious i've never thought about that
because if i see it's not saying no no
wait
no one's piping up brother the only
reason they accepted it because it must
be tits
it must be tears
but surely
when you airdrop something doesn't it
show like a little preview of what
you're sending them or is it just the x
wants to send you this i don't know i'm
sure it shows you a little a little
thumbnail or sometimes definitely
sometimes it does
maybe not maybe maybe sustain a waiter
yeah maybe he had a little cover photo
or not maybe it was in like a notes or
something
it wasn't like it must have been
something like that yeah yeah yeah you
were like oh that's secret that's secret
let me open it up and it's just so cold
yeah just dick dick and nipples
and a tummy
[ __ ] oh
[ __ ] off [ __ ] you must have [ __ ] kitten
30 minutes
bro everybody's accepting that yeah oh
to the side
that's jokes live it that's jokes
[ __ ] hell that's hilarious i've never
thought to airdrop anyone anything oh
public period nah bro that's hilarious
nah bro but to be fair when we was on
the plane the other week yeah i was
editing
clips and i went to airdrop a clip from
my uh thing to uh my phone and when i
did it
yeah i think i could be sending stuff
yeah because i thought i was gonna
accidentally because what the annoying
thing about airdrop is if you leave it
loading yours will come up and then as
you go to click yours it goes yeah i've
sent stuff to people back some bear time
oh okay the hair times oh [ __ ]
i don't use it that much to be fair so
yeah only when i do is like phone to
phone as opposed to a laptop to phone so
yeah yeah you know what um i had a juicy
thing the other day you know uh i saw it
on her tickets you know ash yes
she put on a tick tock over there she
was on a on a flight
and um some brother air-dropped her
uh it must have been on notes or
something or number like numbers or
whatever pages uh but it was not some
crosses oh okay i should win this game
for a face reveal
let's go and choose a back and forth
less no
let's
i'm intrigued already bro juicy long
story short she said she never got the
face reveal i don't think she ever won
oh fair i don't think she ever won but
she said homeboy she said the man of my
dreams could have just
off that plane
i was thinking a thing could never do
that to me oh i the thing is i wouldn't
be able to concentrate on the game i'm
looking around to see he's looking down
playing who's playing games who's
literally playing games with me right
now because i need to scoop you because
this is the sexiest yeah yeah this is
the sexiest the buffets meet cute i can
imagine
i need to know who's on the other side
oh my days
no you know
imagine imagine
imagine brother you did it and you were
gassed yeah and you win the game yeah
and you saw a picture of me like this
close to the camera
it reminds me of that bread around tik
tok that's literally always this close
and his eyes are looking up the black
brother
there's always a brother
that his friend is always recording but
he's recording him here and he's
the angle is so short that he's like
always like this like what are you doing
oh that brother yeah yeah
i can't imagine you would be hilarious i
could imagine you be that guy i would
love to swim to you like that
and the thing is i would i would fall
for because i'd be flirting in between
wanna do this i'll be like nice try sexy
when you try and get me on a little
double cross
and i pattern it and it is drawn nice
try
sexy
with an x yes
i'll be looking around who the [ __ ]
playing with me
who the [ __ ] is playing with me
you're just being two two rows of head
just giggling
you really like this your shoulders
i swear to god if i see your [ __ ]
face i would launch my phone at you
turn the plane around because i'm
launching my phone oh bravo oh i'd
scream james oh i know you had screw i
was so angry i would be howling louder
than you've ever [ __ ] heard no i
would be so satisfying it would to have
you like that in the palm of mind would
be so
so
satisfying
oh my god that's hilarious about pause
but that's hilarious yeah
[ __ ] it out
jesus oh my god sake man that'll be
funny right guys give us
a little
little little little bit of your time
just so we can keep the lights on and
tell you guys how to stay
ultra smooth
with the boys and girls over at manscape
they've brought to you guys the next
level of male grooming we're talking the
ultra smooth package guys okay now the
ultra smooth package is a specialized
groin shaving quit kit
to help you buff protect and smooth tell
them your most sensitive areas okay
we're talking the crop shaver razor the
crop exfoliator and the crop gel okay
guys you no longer have to borrow your
lady ladies razor
for that precise trim
okay guys we all know how hard it is you
get you put blade to skin you get bumps
that's two blading as well that's the
latest skin you get bumps and ingrowns
we don't have to see that we're not here
for that guys so you need that smooth
smooth yeah ultra smooth
okay guys so
if you
live in europe
if you live in europe you live in the
states guys
ultra smooth package that's the one for
you all you need to do is go to
manscape.com and if you want 20 off and
free shipping use the code sng sierra
november golf that's manscape.com guys
the code is sng sierra november golf and
let's get back to the episode thank you
very much well that was uh that was a
very funny trash news all right [ __ ]
what are we up to now what are we doing
um well i'm supposed to do on my [ __ ]
but
jump in do a little something for us
i have a
youtubes i can give you a trash news i
can give you a video run me the video
first
cool
so
the caption is
this man was driving for uber and he
picked up his wife wife with her side
piece
wait till the end i did it i've seen the
first second of it i've not seen i've
not seen it okay
no no no no no
no that's great maybe
yeah you never know you never know
maybe where'd you guys meet
um
we met in a store actually oh
yeah a store
and he said yeah looks like his sister
so yeah
but no it must have been one hell of a
bag yeah yes yeah
yeah
you know yeah
yeah oh you started having a
conversation at the store yeah yeah who
asked you out well i did obviously yeah
he did oh you did that's my number and
then he was like you took his time to
text actually but yeah he can't control
his breathing
yeah
you're right here
okay so is it next to this
this blue toyota huh yeah
yeah okay
how do i know that
how do i know so conveniently
is this blue toyota
man took his arm off immediately
what were you doing with this guy
yeah we're married you've been married
for five years
you know what get out of the car
oh get out of the car
someone said you want to come with me
listen
listen go okay
[Music]
that's what you do to me huh
huh
where are you taking me
this is their house that's putting a
seatbelt back on
five years
we have kids
that's basically it
he couldn't control his breathing he was
breathing hunting what would you do if
you had a bread in the back seat i found
a brother on the back seat yeah not the
my man not the husband the bread are in
the back seat
i laugh when i'm nervous
i laugh when a man said all right get
out of the car i said get out the car oh
my heart will be racing
even if there's a thing
this man is experiencing rage
yeah yeah so even if i thought i can
tamp him up yeah he's not thinking
he would connect a few oh and those few
would hurt because my biggest fear is
like being in a car where the [ __ ] out
of the car
just start
there's nothing i can do
especially i'm going to be like a yap
because i'm going to be there with my
legs
stop stop stop stop stop
stop you need to stop your wife's here
my girl's here stop stop stop
bro
i'll be terrified i'll be terrified i
don't know what he's gonna do fam
oh my i can i could never be the breader
in the back because
it's one of those ones where
you can see how you can see how he was
gas to even tell this story to anybody
to anybody to shop chirps saw a bag and
just chirp stuff chipster i saw the
button down oh i need your number i was
down i need your number obviously i
patent it obviously your boy moves diff
different i was in a shop because shop
who moves to gallon shop
no no you can't do it no one does it bye
and now she's she's i'm in back of uber
she's taking me back to y'all she's
taking me back and we're gonna smash
[Laughter]
i'm in this uber to smash gala i just
met last week bro i'm on different stuff
i'm moving different i'm around here and
everything is comfortable
comfortable man said how do you think i
know it's behind this blue toyota she
said pardon me she said what are you
arguing about
he turned around and took his hood off
and man said this is my wife
fam he slowly removed his arm oh rags he
said what
this arm would have been gone from he
said how do you think i know it as soon
as you start playing games how do you
think i know this is gone and i'm seeing
this the child locks on
just not even on a basic just like the
little figure two years
on a flicky flicky
oh that's nice
[Music]
i know where this is going
i know where this is going i'll be right
limiting and i'll be knocking on it
[Music]
if mine is locked i'd be like open your
side immediately trying to i would lose
composure
try and open your side immediately
the sun hasn't tried it's cracking me up
try to open your side up immediately
this is a ploy fam he's testing us get
out get out now
now because i don't know what's about to
happen are you both in on it yeah yeah
you're playing with me
you're playing with me and i said get
out of the car and dragged him out the
car
it's not his fault bro in that three
second gap where he's out and yeah i
would have i would have been cussing her
man said are you sure you don't want to
come with me yeah do you want to come
with me i would have been like you're a
[ __ ] dick
[ __ ] dick
[ __ ] house
this is your wife this is your take let
me get out get out get your hands off me
i'll get out i'll get out
you deserve better man bro working a
second job renting
like running ubers
bro that's um yeah be smart yeah yeah be
smart
like yeah don't how dare you how dare
you next man's yard and she was talking
the most she was talking the juices she
was giggling and gaggling oh yeah he
chose me this he got my number this he
man said he took too long to re to
message me after he got my number
he talked too long while you're in your
husband's bed you're waiting
you're waiting
oh that's that i would i would want to
outline her
just oh yeah
that's different i couldn't
because this there's nothing
more better
than it is escorting your wife
you're escorting your wife
and her cheat
to
your yard your yard you're not listen
you're not a man
there's no other words to describe and
it's not even your fault it's not it's
really not it's not even your fault bro
but you are escorting your wife and her
ting you're a cuck at this point yeah
[ __ ] you're carriaging
this [ __ ] so you're from the whole
thing doing up chauffeur and everything
and man got back where did he take her
that's what i wanted to go back in the
car and please leave her back on and
she's thinking this is our house
the toyota is outside where are you
taking me
where the [ __ ] are you she didn't ask
enough questions i think she was still
rattled by the game because she was she
was thinking what lies can i tell
because
there's no way out he's recording the
whole thing yeah he's got you on dash
cam
saying that you got chirps in a shop
that's giggling giggling arm round
playing with his fingers like this she's
thinking there's no way i can lie
i said we have kids we have kids
together five years yawn to be fair
i hate when they say stuff like that
well that we have kids five years we've
got kids
[Music]
boring so
i'm a cheat
do you understand
you're discussing with the chief yeah
i do what i want you when i won yeah i'm
a cheap bro kids is kids it's kids packs
you can feed them anyway yeah big man it
don't mean you're you're trying nonsense
you are chatting nonsense
we've got kids and
i might be trying to not you knew that
yeah you knew that when you met out here
trying to knock my g and you're chatting
about kids i cheated on my ex with you
that's how we got together
that's how we got together selfish
and you're chatting about five years and
kids sue me you're literally explaining
reasons why i'm cheating on you if
you're not gonna arrest me let me out of
the car basically if you're not gonna
arrest me
get me out this car because i need to go
home kidnap me or let me out one of the
two you're chatting [ __ ] you're just
chatting you're just making noises
you've got kids big man
what are you doing you're negotiating
with a criminal
basically i've been cheating you just
clocked me today i don't i never
subscribed to this how could you start i
noticed you're angry and what is that
boring boring boring
just tell to suck her mom and leave
tell her to suck her mom and lip and
lead bro because she's going to cheat
again anyway
she's going to cheat again she was
comfortable i would i wouldn't say
nothing if i was him the main the driver
or the moment if i was if i was the the
my man
i would have asked i would have been
like say less
i wouldn't have done nothing like this
is my wife none of that yeah yeah i
would have gently said is this behind
the toyota all right say less
um
i would have took my hood off mm-hmm
the mask off yeah and i'm like all right
and as they
as they're about to get out i'll turn
around the blood no no you stay i
wouldn't say anything
he would be like you leave you stay he
blocked the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going
on excuse me
she's staying here and you're getting
out
tell him he's leaving and you're staying
it should be like you need to leave you
need to leave he would be rattled
he would be rattled
bro that's the only way to play it
that's that's a good way to play he
leaves you station but you you're gonna
need to leave you don't don't do
anything you're gonna don't need to
aggravate him
just leave
he doesn't see straight when he's in
this fight he's not gonna yeah he can't
hear you right now close the door behind
you please please for your own safety
walk back home fam man will close the
door
i'll roll the thing and say there's a
good boy
roll up the window
and i'm dropping her on the m6 yes
i'll leave her into the middle of the
motorway get the [ __ ] out get out
literally i'll just she should be where
are you taking me james why are you
taking me you pull up on a hard shoulder
i pull up on the hard shoulder
ask her to leave if she doesn't get out
i will just literally politely open the
door
get a fist over here and just not even
like yank it just slowly slowly caress
her out there slowly pull her out the
car
leave her there
get back in the car
and then as she tries to get back in you
want to leave him here she tries to i'll
give her one of them
my face
and then she'll back up i'll get in and
i'll just
i'll readjust my mirrors
check your blind spot
peel off
and you can see here in the back there
i don't even make eye contact
she's getting smaller and smaller and
smaller and smaller
and that's when the rest of my life
starts that's hilarious she'll come home
the locks have changed that's hilarious
bro i couldn't give her this i can't
give her the satisfaction of this this
is my wife yeah yeah five years it's
just like i just drove you home yeah
i'm i'm here i'm so small in this
situation you've taken every every ounce
of my manhood
there's no way i'm allowing you to see
an emotional reaction out of me
but anyway that is that's tragic that is
tragic um
so a slight one i've got a very short
twitter hall of fame
for myself okay
um
for this
so i've literally got one two three four
five six seven seven
hall of fame tweets let's go that i just
had a look on you guys you guys know
your boy doesn't really [ __ ] with
twitter too much um but i thought i was
bored yesterday not bored but i was just
doing some recon yesterday and i thought
you know what let me contribute okay
let me contribute just a few that that
tickled me okay tickled me and angered
me i hope you i hope and none of the
seven are any of the ones i've got
probably i'll do that so i apologize in
advance all right i'll just delete you
all right cool
this one is literally what we were just
talking about okay
man said he's tickling his work wife and
she's saying stop
stop
while his girlfriend at home planning a
new act of service to make him remember
the spark they once had
bro
yeah i saw that one and that that
infuriated me
wow that's so dark
girlfriends are planning a new act of
service that's dark to remember the
spark they once had while he's tickling
next
field stop stop stop we're at work stop
stop
be ned i'll play with you later monster
start
[Music]
that's hilarious never
all right
sorry this one this one this one oh
you're gonna do one no
this one is current in 2022.
i'm listed
fam it says man beyond here getting
bullied into saying stuff like i want my
woman to have a lot of bodies
i think i've seen that one bro i think
i've seen that yeah yeah i think i've
seen that one i've seen that one yeah
yeah mad mad mad man i can't get away
with saying anything these days yeah
that's nuts i don't want a woman who
slept with bear man yeah you're a [ __ ]
or
that's that's the treatment yeah you're
a [ __ ] all day that's mad that's mad
yeah
this one trauma
trauma hit me so i was dating this guy
kind of rich and he asked me out of the
blue
would you date a struggling guy
and i said no
and he said
you know
to me
you're the struggling guy
i haven't healed yet
fam plot twist plot her world would have
been rashford she felt wined and dined
you're the poor [ __ ] bro would you
would you date a broke guy
no
no
do you realize in this situation
you're the broke guy
wow
what's a comeback fan she
and in that setting yeah she doesn't
understand why she's being attacked yeah
yeah fine she doesn't understand
i'm just here for food and give you
[ __ ] that's all i'm here for
why are you saying this why are you
attacking me aren't you satisfied bro
that's wow
you're the brother guy
you're the broke guy
i'm eating up my surf and turf
[ __ ]
[ __ ] what a what a comeback you're a
hypocrite i i asked you out because i
want you to admit you're a hypocrite
basically it's basically what i said
you're a [ __ ] hypocrite that's jokes
[Music]
this one
someone says someone tweeted
someone tweeted men should understand
that some of these girls bring friends
to a date because of safety
not for food and drinks some replied
then why are they eating and drinking
they should be out here checking the
perimeter
on some surveillance watch tick
wow that's jokes that is she eating food
why is she here why is she in the
restaurant why is she eating food and
why am i paying fax surveilling the area
for them ops that's hilarious oh fam fam
this one sweetie
i think this is an old one
right
so this is for a white bread that said
this right yeah yeah yeah
and [ __ ] called me gay because i ain't
shake my skittles before i ate them some
replied uh who
they replied
me
a who a [ __ ] all caps and [ __ ] i said
what i said why are you asking me
questions correctly
what funniest tweet i've read i'm
shaking the skittles it's such an it's
such a black african thing to do i mean
afro-caribbean things literally
peanuts
my dad used to do a bombay mix and he
used to frustrate me
he would shake it like this and he'd pop
it like that he just releases the
knuckle enough to get one in and
oh and choose it hard
choose it hard oh so they know it's not
no gaiting yeah i'm eating a mansion out
here my dad chews hard when he's eating
anything black he's chewing it
bombay mix
nuts skittles two jokes
that's two shakes
and he he he yams it
yeah man you gotta let them know camel
chew you gotta let them know
oh that's jokes
okay stop shooting me a girl on my snap
posting bear suicidal [ __ ] about jumping
off bridges etc so what asked if she's
okay and she replies i've got a man
i'm so vex i read that word earlier that
is a great man that's a great one
hilarious women are
just texted me come home as the leader
of the group or don't come home at all
wow
come home as the leader of the so not
only is she saying you are currently not
the leader do whatever you need to do to
become the leader before you chop this
[ __ ] dinner time because otherwise bro
it's in your yard don't say your yard
anymore come home as the leader or don't
come home that's just like asking one of
these running rounds to go dump you off
the shane bro rags
come home as deshane or don't come home
at all you're top boy or you're nothing
wow
pressure why aren't you that's pressure
why aren't you i've got bills to pay
allow it that's pressure value life
first
life first oh my days why aren't you him
that's the life the mandom has to live
in why aren't you him yeah this this
leader stopped me
and i deserve him i deserve the leader
why do you deserve that why do you think
you deserve the lead bro some of it is
mad it's that from the leader of group
stuff it's it doesn't
it's facts as long as it's belittling to
a man it's like when a trend arises
as long as it is belittling to a man
a woman reads it and is like
well that's actually that's actually
facts though like we should only be
dealing with the top way out yeah yeah
if he's not top bread i don't understand
why i'm in this situation why am i
receiving messages from baiters yeah
yeah why yeah my man
isn't the leader like i know for a fact
my man's not the leader of the group
so
why am i with him why am i with him what
might i actually do they actually sit
down and ponder like hmm yeah oh that's
what i was gonna say because yeah
most
not all
a lot
of women assume that they
are leader of the group material
so i saw i kept saying this thing on
ticks brett um kept asking girls write
yourself out ten yes yes yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah everyone's
saying 10. bogus
which is cool uplifting
but when you classify yourself as 10
yeah
you automatically assume that you get
leader of the group
but because it's like just the same way
there's only one leader of the group in
each group yeah
you're not leader of the group
ting
that's why you're not with the leader of
the group facts which is why you're
barking at me to become the leader yeah
yeah
because you refuse to accept your flaws
yeah
you don't want to accept yourself she
doesn't want to look in the mirror
yeah yeah yeah why are you not with the
leader yeah because i'm not the leader
yeah
and you're with me and you're saying i
need to become the leader because you
know you can't get the leader facts she
needs to look in the mirror yeah admit
it look in the mirror look at your flaws
i'll become leader when you admit that
you're not lead equality
and when i become leader
if the girl replied come home as a
leader of the group or don't come over
at all i'll be like when i become leader
of the group make sure you're not at
home yeah make sure your bags are packed
because my ting is on the wall bringing
back leader group material leader group
[ __ ] is on the way yeah and you're not
here when i become leader i'm bringing
home this leader [ __ ]
so you best not be home
oh
i was actually joking you love to take
things too far and i'm done with you
that's the those are the three messages
you'll get back to back-to-back wait to
hurt me every other sentence
because i was only joking you know this
is a trend and you take things way too
far i'm done with you you literally find
any excuse to belittle me it's
astounding to me that i still part with
my girls have told me so many times
everyone tells me i should leave you and
i'm i'm always defending you and this is
actually how you treat me i can't
believe it
i'm shell-shocked i'm gobsmacked you're
a [ __ ] prick
and that's when the spike starts yeah
yeah once she addressed that you're
a piece of [ __ ] yeah that's when she has
poetic license to say
and do you know what's actually funny
that's what it starts
you get a break yeah you get just this
this this i'm done yeah and then you
like
whatever whatever man i'm so tired of
this [ __ ] and then there's it's five
minutes gap and then you
this is and it's never one pound yeah
yeah yeah so you actually think it's a
phone call or is it a couple tests which
one is it ringing or what can you look
and then you see the first one you know
what's actually funny and you're like
here we go
you see that read more at the bottom
here we go and then she'll abuse you
you abuse you abuse you
then play the victim so then you have to
pander to them yeah yeah yeah yeah you
have to air all the abuse
read into the victim nonsense and then
you'll be like look look
i didn't even mean it it's just when you
say stuff
you need to do this you need to do that
you're always complaining that this and
i'm always in your corner fighting for
you and then you get home and you [ __ ]
and then the vicious cycle starts again
the visual cycle starts again tomorrow
far it's horrible [ __ ] it's absolutely
that was hilarious that was hilarious
right i have jesus
and am i the [ __ ] oh gang okay right
man said boys am i the [ __ ]
not even on my house am i the [ __ ]
he's been taken for a mug bro
me and my fiance oh god
oh god
oh
fiancee
cool cool cool right
me and my fiance have been together
since we were 18
and are still together
happy and even have a daughter okay okay
they are my world guys i'll do anything
for them going
strong start
me and my girl got together because my
psycho ex
who i had a restraining order against
that 17 god was her best friend and
wanted to get back in contact with me
but couldn't because of the restraining
order
so he got with her best friend mad fam
mad
mad
i wonder she's crazy
fast forward 10 years
um the ex and my girl are friends again
and believe me when i say this
she
is
lang
the the psycho guess
oh
oh my god bro but more importantly she's
putting it on me oh my god together
my missus knows nothing and i'm so
tempted
what the [ __ ] should i do
i think i i think i know that i should
just come clean before anything happens
but it's keeping me awake
please help me lads
i'll even show you the eggs if it needs
to because she's bad oh
this is not show us
i'm replying now show us
i'm not interested in anything else show
up
this is not how i thought this would go
when you said i might [ __ ] and he
said fiance i was thinking oh we're in
this is going to spiral out of control
bro wow boro
so recap
bless
recap he's with us he's with the love of
his life he's got a door but he had a
psycho ex who has got he he has a
restraining order on age of 17. so
instead of getting with her he got with
her best friend yeah at 17
he got 17 he was with this girl she was
crazy so crazy had to put a restraining
order on her during the rest once he put
the strain order in he got with her best
mate they've been together for for 10
years and they're engaged to be wed and
they've got a daughter together and he
loves his life yeah he loves his wife
the restraining order has expired
and they've become veterans again she
has told her i'm over it have him come
over it you got a daughter oh i'm happy
for you guys
[Laughter]
and she sees homeboy
and he's grown into his body
and the beard's full of the chest
less i want him now
i want to [ __ ] you
she's putting paws on mine
on him and he wants half of him is like
i should just
i should tell my missus and get her out
of our lives yeah yeah she's crazy yeah
but the other half is she is banging and
crazy [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
and i haven't [ __ ] a newting in 10
years yeah yeah that's everything's
weighing up on it yeah and the pros and
cons of this is beating
like like
he's literally out of these chests on
some usher takes
[Music]
some
[ __ ]
icebox thing
bro he don't know what to do yeah yeah
help wow
this is a really good one
and he reiterated the fact mandam i'm
telling you i will show you a picture
she is banging
[ __ ] you can't haphazardly tell me to do
the right thing here because she's so
length is what he's saying
he said don't jump to conclusions yeah
banging bro [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
um
i don't want to sit him and say he
should go and bang this girl yeah
because
it's it's just categorically the wrong
thing yeah 100 i know your your pain and
you want him to understand yeah this is
real
these situations are real they're really
real but it's like
he he can't ruin what he's got this is
this is his world he's his daughter and
his wife are his wild he's engaged to be
wed suit and she's just come out of the
woodworks after her 10-year restraining
order
and now she's looking thicker than the
snicker and looking juicy she's got them
dick sucker lips and she's and she's
just putting paws on man in public she's
saying she's saying flirting and doing
all of this stuff
she's she's being a naughty little kitty
cat oh that's and he knows it's
forbidden
from [ __ ] yeah it's the
but you know what's mad i just deemed
he's [ __ ] on both already yeah yeah
so he
but he hasn't banged this crazy thing in
he's lived a life yeah
and she's just
i i want to see what she looks like i
need i need i need to see how pink she
is because if she's just banging is what
he's painting what does he look like i
don't know oh he thinks blocked off yeah
[ __ ] yeah if i knew what he looked like
we could get a general yeah you know
what i mean that's what i was like what
does he look like yeah
because if he's all right yeah he only
needs to be like six and up for me to
believe that she's banging she must be
yeah yeah [ __ ]
um [ __ ] what should he do because i'm
thinking if i was in his shoes
that would definitely keep me up at
night
it would definitely that would
definitely keep me up at night james i'm
not gonna lie to you and i'm not gonna
lie to you that would definitely keep me
up at night
and that's petrifying i think
i think what he should do he needs
to
right i'm an auntie now that's too funny
right
this is sound advice right
i think you need to
for your own personal later satisfaction
so hear me out you need to lean into
this
as far as you can without breaking any
rules
so just back back and forth flirting
yes but innocent like you need complete
and utter deniability yep
but you need to know in your head oh she
wants to [ __ ] yeah you need to get that
solidified oh she will definitely [ __ ]
yeah and then you need to wank over that
thought
every day for like six days until you're
bored of it yeah
you have to but you can't do it for much
longer it can't be longer than six days
yeah because now it's a kink and an
obsession
yeah that's just how it works relate
that to bonus yeah
you have to do it yeah minimal amount of
time to just remember the feeling of i
love my wife i love my wife
every time you not god i love my wife
yeah every time you know god yeah she's
a scam yeah she's disgusting god i love
my wife yeah just do it bare times yeah
until it's out of your system and then
hopefully maybe
if she's in your yard and you're running
says wank there so when you're in that
pnc you can see her
yeah yeah a little harlot yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah a little jezebel 10
minutes of recovery yeah you've got
perfect clarity yeah let it float with
you then um and you'll be like yeah yeah
you'll be disgusting you'll get off me
my wife said my daughter said are you
taking a piss stop it
yeah honestly stop stop it i'm actually
over you yeah it's been 10 years relax
yeah
please chill please chill you're
embarrassing yourself
but but you but you can't you really
can't forget to have these wants
because if you allow yourself in that
that that area to build up is to build
up good lord yeah you're going to trust
that you're going to burst inside yeah
and she will feel she will facilitate a
situation in which it can happen oh i
promise
100 this 100
a decade oh
she's in your lives regularly now
because she's classed as the auntie now
yeah the best friends are rekindled it's
not an accident that she's back in your
life it's not men have a very easy time
of playing naive
when it suits them yeah
don't be naive
and scheme this she will throw you under
the bus you put a restraining order on
her yeah she's got vengeance yeah yeah
yeah yeah she wants justice yeah bro
yeah don't fall for it i need to see
what she looks like yeah james i don't
think you understand i need to see what
she looks like
restraining all the [ __ ] yeah
i need to see what she looks like she
she'll swallow your balls holes
she'll swallow your balls like
her tongue will be up your ass while she
swallows your balls
good sir because you're in trouble
restraining order pum that's different
none of us have experienced that none of
us have issues you need to get out of it
[ __ ] she's been she's been plotting and
scheming for years
that's too funny as soon as you not
you'll realize what she's uh as soon as
you know and you know we know you're not
going to pull out if you're not oh
you're leaving it enough you're going to
keep she's going to be on top she's 100
oh yeah she's holding the youth she's
holding it in and then that's when
everything starts to fall apart because
she knows no matter what she can get
your your girl back as her bridget fat
especially when she holds your you
because they'll just rekindle over what
piece what you are
and then you'll be paying child support
for both of these men
she will just be thinking they'll be
doing our play dates sam vengeance is
mine and you're living with mum oh my
god i need to see what she looks like
yeah
bro don't do it don't don't do it don't
do it but show us the picture yeah
right show us the picture and fap over
it
restraining order [ __ ] yes crazy
wow
right we've got ig questions we do have
ig questions
um so the ig question of this week guys
was
what did the person you were interested
in do to make you completely lose
interest
cool
and as per usual guys responses
juicy woo see some are just running
through okay yeah
took her out to dinner and she ate pasta
with her hands oh my god what found out
he'd been to court for slapping a girl
around the face with a spatula
how did you find that out
wow
that would have left and oh that's her
that's left indent she would have had
like three white stripes on her face
she would have been in court judge would
be like one for your
posted a pic of him and his girlfriend
18 months into our relationship
certainly balls of absolute like granite
like solid planet how can you lie for so
long
nothing
just feel nothing
do you know what i mean
no resentment no remorse just nothing
bro i'm posting it i'm tired of finding
excuses not to post it i'm posting it
[ __ ] what she's saying shut up
hold this ellen sharp
i'm telling you now
thanks i'm literally telling you now
she's telling you and the world now
she's my girl yeah
18 months
wow
ah
he said he'd he said he'd had multiple
wanks that day to try then have come and
[ __ ] me with a broken dick
that's risky bro i feel for that guy
yeah i actually feel for that guy he's
tough
he said he liked incest
he started calling me bro in front of my
she started calling me bro in front of
my friends
oh she was trying to [ __ ] around
she didn't want that man to know yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she's she's for
the streets yeah this is play play she's
on run this is my bedroom she's on road
man are moving
he wanted
he wanted me to eat us
and was trying to get us to use a
double-ended dildo
fair play at least you had it with chest
fax
his sister his sister put him in a
headlock he genuinely couldn't get out
brown
i would genuinely
get out i'd be in
wind the life out of my sister
[ __ ] off me
get a [ __ ] off me you're in front of my
girl impossible
no
no shared bath water with his dad
that's disgusting shed bath water yeah
yeah and you know dads are just busted
man that water was so much
after a long day
merch oh and he was definitely using a
bar or something no showers another a
bar of soap and he was the thing is he
wasn't like wiping over himself yeah he
was using the soap on his body
he was
in the bar
specs he was using the actual box let it
sit in the water and get smaller and
smaller
you just watched it float away oh one
awesome oh my dave's disgusted he told
me a story of how he dislocated his
shoulder fist pump in the air
oh that's pathetic pathetic
that's actually so thick got soft as i
was riding him
that's job
here's your business swallowed her
swallowed her fingernails after cutting
them and acted like she spat them out
acted like she spat them out
and just backed it
i couldn't i pro bro
i promise you i promise you i ah
i
i couldn't catch eye contact after that
she couldn't i should like what i spat
out first of all why are you biting it
second of all where are you spinning
where is it yeah i saw you swallow it i
literally saw heard you swallow it don't
lie to me don't lie to me i'm not like
show me the evidence where is it where
is it it's a shag carpet bro i can't
find it in here firstly why are you
biting at facts facts why are you back
you know why are you biting it where you
spitting it and why are you sweating
immediately
yeah i would leap across delivery matter
oh i want to fight her
how could you lie to me like that oh it
is
cut
cut his hair and expose his ears he
reminded me of the fa cup trophy and i
told him that too
bro babes i cut my hair what do you
think you look like the fa cup trophy
that thing is fam the cup is small the
handle
[ __ ] off his arm was shaking when he
flexed his muscles
that's like that's impractical
look at my muscles
that long
line under the bicep those tendons are
straining [ __ ]
[ __ ] man don't do my life man
after 18 months of dating he said my
girlfriend would like you
is this the same breath 18 months ago
trauma trauma my girlfriend would like
you after letting him suck my feet
found out he was gay and [ __ ] a guy in
my friend's circle
that feet sucking thing was irrelevant
yeah he was looking what do you mean
after i let him suck on my feet
what what would you do i mean she's
moving like i said after he met my mom
fam
after her i i let him suck my feet he
banged a guy in my friendship group
like the audacity i let you suck my
finger i let you suck my [ __ ] feet
like this it's a clear indication yeah
that we're meant to be
i don't get it like
after i let him suck my feet
[ __ ] sake
that's too funny his eyes cross when he
nuts
bro speaking of have you seen that that
[ __ ] trend i hate how much it gets me
when the girls do that [ __ ] face the
eye cross with the tongue out face oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that is too bad it doesn't matter who
does it as well oh that's not what i'm
talking what are you talking about
outfit is the the filter where their
eyes are rolling
[Music]
what is it called it's called like some
animating oh the hey goat thing
this thing
yeah
i'm sure it's called a hago site like
that
or he go something similar i don't know
i don't know what it's called ego
no it's not
yeah is he going i'm sure yeah ego you
go you go okay ego you go
it's buff yeah i've i've seen and it is
it's a manipulation of like the
chromosomes
do you know what i mean i don't know
exactly because it's stupid it's stupid
but this dependent on the female
it just brings out science six top murks
yeah easy time
because they pick the right ones yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah there's just
[Music]
[Laughter]
love poster in his bedroom
wet that is wet picked her nose and
pinged the bogeys across the room like
it was an olympic sport
you would you would definitely leave
across the living room to the back of it
started pinging bogeys
you
definitely oh we've smelt so bad it
nearly knocked me out
i've smelled
dusty weave before we all have in a wine
we all have this vex what you're willing
to tolerate
[Music]
because the the bundas too soft
and then you just get the
smoky weave and you're just like
it's just this is it's one of the ones
where you're whining you're just looking
around now yeah the wine is like yeah
she's looking up but it is what it is
and then she tries to get
the arch yeah
stop start literally stop stop
he picked me up for our date on an
electric scooter
woke up to him blame the playing the
guitar to me
like some patrick did it patrick felt
too hot to handle
she got a fade like she was mandem i had
to cut her up with immediate effect oh
rags i remember seeing one bath team one
time walking walk into my barbers and i
thought she was looking for the braid
girl
and she just copped a squat and man's
like just
chopping her up
and i was like
that's brave they're rocking there are
a minuscule of women that that can put
no not even a fade yeah short hair yeah
like a shortcut yes a few women i could
pull that off but a fake a
fade if i see if i walk into henrik's
barbershop yeah yeah i mean i see
just and he's he's holding the cranium
like this
and he's just literally lining up
rubbing it
scrubbing it i'd have to look in the
mirror twice is that lady yeah is that a
lady
that you're doing this too bro man could
never be getting that flick
all right that's impossible with and
he's lining up light from the
it's like sideburns nev never
never challenge ladies send me or us or
whoever
someone that you know that's got a
lineup but you believe she's banging i'm
intrigued to see him i'm intrigued it's
the dreading is when the fade starts to
grow out
oh yeah that's butter she has to
continue with the face yeah you have to
have a fade now because in this in
intermediary period yeah you're not
you
you you can't go shopping on a track you
can't go sharp you're objectively
unattractive
and you did it to yourself which makes
it worse
you're growing out your fate
what i could never and like she looks
like she's supposed to be like you know
you see things like she looks like she's
supposed to be
yeah she's not yeah yeah like one she
was like oh sorry about the hair i'm
just trying to grow out my fade imagine
you're what
my face my skin fade
i'm so confused what do you mean yeah
like homeboy
faded line me up blended me up
did he use the the this is on the side
yeah yeah the works bro
the what you have is what i have yeah i
had it why i just wanted it something
different and now it's growing out it
looks hideous
oh my god okay i got a few more go go go
when he stood on these tiptoes to be
taller than me
tough
that was literally my first day yeah
remember you see that was literally my
first day with my ex wore jeans and
trainers to the beach
that's disgusting
that's offensive and disgusting i don't
know what's going through people's minds
when i see stuff like that there were
definitely like
some kind of puma
that he was wearing
the long white ones with the yeah the
tongue that starts at the toe
he was wearing them tings
he moaned oh dear when he came after 30
seconds
[Laughter]
oh dear oh i'm just like dude regret and
pleasure so tight you're just like
you're banging away are you once you
feel that tingle tingle you've ever got
two you've got two options you pull out
and breathe yeah or you bang you go for
gold
and he chose option b there and just
banged her i said i couldn't help it
dear
[ __ ] that ruined
thank you yeah
oh sensational oh dear
[Music]
i've ruined everything we had oh okay
okay i needed that i had two choices and
i chose the wrong choice i'm sorry i
chose door a i don't give a [ __ ]
that was good to me
she said kept raw potatoes bread and red
wine in the fridge
slept with me and then said sorry i'm
just not that attracted to you
that was homeboy from that am i the
[ __ ] the other week
i don't remember my man said she came to
my yard catfish oh mike and he's still
right
why did he fight for her for [ __ ] sake
literally why did you
all right last one
invited me to a house party which turned
out to be a sex party his friend was
banging some go in front of everyone
then out of nowhere the guy leaned over
and sucked his dick multiple times
he then called me later and said i don't
know what's wrong with me i just like
sucking my friend's dick
what is this
i honestly could not sit multiple times
that's so disgusting that's
do you want to come to this house party
next thing you know your man's is on his
knees sucking his brethren's dick
as a i'm not even the girl but as a boy
if you were like bro do you want to come
to this house party with me and i'm like
yeah say let's yeah get in there
and there's just cheeks there's cheeks
and i'm a bit like what i know a bit
like rust
all right it's double in it you tricked
me you literally we're here now we're
here let's get to it there's more
titties than cockroaches right here and
then i see a prayer i recognize through
you yeah just banging it yeah
just
banging here in the delivery in front of
everyone and i'm like swear down us and
you don't say anything you just make a b
line towards him get on your knees and
slop him
and he just cups the back of your head
i'm like yeah oh oh
and then you come back to me and say
let's get some punch
you don't speak about anything let's get
let's see let's get some punches
dehydrated
this vibe still a couple laps and i'm
like yo yeah i swear and then again
you'd suck you suck a dick again
multiple multiple times throughout the
evening you've returned you're not
sucking anyone else you keep sucking
them off that's the only gay stuff
you're doing here
you've been chatting about yats with me
but you keep returning to this pipe
james i can't i don't know what's wrong
with me and you'd ring me the next day
and say bro you haven't addressed the
tool side of the whole the whole time
are we leaving and i'm in shock
i was shocked because we share a car
and you went back i'm terrified
and you bail me and you drop me off
you're blessed bless and i'm like cool i
get in and when you don't you close the
door and you're leaning yeah yeah yeah
oh my god what was that what happened
who can i tell
my phone starts ringing our answer i'm
like hello and you're like bro i'm not
gonna lie i don't know what's wrong with
me i just love sucking his dick
first of all we're so relieved you've
addressed it
first emotion is pure sweet release
and secondly i wouldn't know what i i
would scream like bro
thank
one why are you sucking his dick so
much i can't
help i just love it i just told you i
can't help it
how often are you sucking his dick bro
always
whenever it's out he just tells me i'm
at this location he drops a pin and i
know i'm here for throat that's it i
don't ask for anything in return and he
just keeps banging things but he just
lets me slop it and i love it [ __ ]
hell bro
i'm not the guy to help you through this
i'm really really not i said bro
thank you
thank you for addressing it sweet relief
i'll be like that's what i feel when i
see that dick fam sweet release sweet
relief and then i carry on i'm seeing
things i'm seeing things but as soon as
i see that [ __ ]
i need it in my mouth
i can't return
i can't help it yeah i'll be like bro
i'm sorry man like i can't
unpack this with you i really can't
because what i just saw has scarred me
for life we can't be boys anymore
because you're
you're insane
you're insane
you're just moving so
yeah we've literally been boys for years
and years and years and you're just out
here slopping tall from one brother
that's what makes it so much worse
bizarre
that's the word bro it's bizarre
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
yo
that choice of work was the best
placement of anything i've ever heard
[Laughter]
because there's no explanation
i said it's a bizarre
that's the funniest thing
[ __ ] oh guys thank you again there's
always so much fun
oh thank you for sticking with us this
is a super long one this might be one of
our longest ever um but as always guys
catch you on
patreon.com not we'll see you next week
shits and thursday
monday love love
[Music]